[Music]
it's Thursday time for final exam we
find out which Fox employees and
contributors have been paying attention
to their jobs covering the news
this week's contestants correspondent
Griff Jenkins and Fox News at night host
Shannon bream Shannon has been a buzz
saw as you know in this competition
defeating all six opponents she has
faced here are her opponents from weeks
past Wow
that is just a murderer's row and she's
she's crushed them all
perhaps Griff is up to the challenge to
switch things up and to give you a
fighting chance we have put Shannon in a
different seat figure out maybe it's the
seat that's doing it and I've been put
in the Thunderdome and you have Turner's
my good mojo is on that chair and that
buzzer so our producer Alex McCaskill
who wrote these questions said these are
particularly tough so we'll see if he's
right okay hands on the buzzer here's
how it works I'm gonna ask the questions
the first one to buzz in gets to answer
you have to wait until I finish asking
the question in order to do that each
correct answer worth one point if you
get it wrong you lose a point best of
five wins all the winner will be awarded
a prize I'm gonna keep secret for the
moment okay first up one of Donald
Trump's celebrity arch enemies possibly
facing jail time tonight for bribery
that is because she offered millions of
dollars to Republican senators to inject
the tax bill you have to wait on
finished which celebrity was it shannon
bream Rosie O'Donnell Rizzo doll oh all
right tripped by the rules well we'll
see if she's right - the tape is it
Rosie O'Donnell Rosie O'Donnell going
off the rails trying to
hiding in Park promised to give two
million dollars to Senator Susan Collins
and two million to Senator Jeff Flake if
they vote well as many on Twitter much
to point out those bribes would be
illegal she also told her followers to
call 9-1-1 it's like The Hague we have
to follow rules here mark Marist College
is out with its poll of the most
annoying words and phrases of 2017 there
were a lot in competition obviously the
most annoying year in human history in
second place was the phrase fake news
which annoying word one Grif Jenkins
whatever know which annoying word one
two the tape is whatever correct the
most joy words or phrases Mary's hold
people to find out the top five fake
news that's second you've got twenty
three percent of the votes and look at
that number one whatever three percent
of respondents and it is the most
annoying word for nine years whatever
she's good don't be fooled by the
niceties she's taking it's one to one
Apple the company's in trouble with its
customers after admitting it
deliberately does what to its older
iPhones Shannon brings those them down
slows them down I don't believe that
let's see if the TIC confirms it Apple
confirming longtime conspiracy theory
admitting it purposely slows down the
performance of its older iPhones after
some of the new models a release the
company claiming it does this not to
push people to buy the newer models that
are more expensive but instead to keep
the older phones from crashing I have an
old iPhone I think it's slowing
both I know it's slowing down so I'm
eating fish I speak from experience your
answer was correct but I don't believe
their explanation it's really for your
benefit that we're making with how slow
this bonus I find a Google cheating Siri
was here to help you yes next question
multiple choice question this week a
former Navy pilot revealed on this show
actually that an object in the sky he
saw was quote not from Earth he
described this unidentified flying
object as being in the shape of candy
which candy was a shaped like was it a a
tic-tac be a candy corn see a skill and
I'll throw in deep Butterfinger just for
the heck of it Tic Tac candy corn
skittle Butterfinger this is throwing it
out there because I have no idea but I
like tic tacs you like tic tacs it's
okay if likes tic tacs
is it a tic-tac he came across an
aircraft that he says was quote not
something from Earth he was shaped like
a tic tac it had no wings look at you
you gotta go all-in against a very
various - okay so we've been we've
actually been here before people have
been to the precipice of victory over
shannon bream in fact they're littered
on the valley floor of their bodies okay
so it's - - this is the decisive
question are you ready you feeling good
no I'm not I'm like an old iPhone okay
final question
Disney has unveiled its new robot
version of the President of the United
States Donald Trump it's in the Hall of
Presidents exhibit in the Magic Kingdom
there's a problem though many say the
robot looks nothing like the president
but like which actor instead
Shannon Breen john-boy well that's a
weird guess if you get this right you
win - the tape some on the internet say
it looks like a bloated jonvoyage envoy
it's never going to speak
oh look at that Shannon brain ladies and
gentlemen I can't believe it okay so you
win this week we run our prizes so this
week we have a small bottle of
non-alcoholic champagne that we're going
to give like it do I get to like spray
it it takes a lot like bubbly water but
it's it's delicious if I shake it it's
from France Super Bowl Louie the stage
manager saying go grab Shannon thank you
both very much thank you thank you for
walking me to the precipice almost that
big slaughter but I am honored pay
attention to the news every week you can
play along another edition of final exam
on Thursday right here
[Music]